McDonald's CEO explains why it takes
people's favorite items off the menu
because he's a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
[Music]
this may seem like almost useless
information but I just figured it's so
darn relatable and we almost talk about
it every other day anyway it's about you
no it's about McDonald's thank you Ryan
it's not McDonald's I could offer a lot
of expertise on McDonald's I [ __ ]
love McDonald's dude whoa yo okay all
right hey chill Alec chill Mr Baldwin
chill don't [ __ ] around my McDonald's
that was extremely angry and passionate
what's what's your absolute everybody's
absolute favorite thing about McDonald's
I'll tell you right now go in the past
okay maybe you last uh everybody goes
back to when he was a child
you just cut off his flashback dude [ __ ]
was getting blurry and then you just
like cleared it up okay fine in the past
in the past two years this is what I've
been ordering because it changes I
always get the Double Quarter Pounder
with cheese
I say add Mac sauce that is [ __ ] good
like that if you guys ever added Mac
sauce I did it because of you and I'm
very excited thank you
don't touch him don't touch him don't
touch him do I get that and then I
always get I always get a second side
dish sometimes it's a fish fillet or
sometimes it's chicken nuggets on the
side
do you get the combo with the Double
Quarter Pounder are you comboing that oh
waste and what's your beverage choice
special McDonald's Coke it's it's
different than any other Coke in the
world so I get coke with extra ice so
they can pack it up and I get large they
fill it all up to the top we know your
front though because of your successful
get lean program over the last four
months where you totally haven't been
eating this how do you turn that into
muscle stir it
all right all right there Nick what's
your favorite steroids at McDonald's I
always go I always have to order like
chicken nuggies yup right always got
some chicken what sauce to use though
sweet and sour yeah loser
barbecue dude I like to inside I like I
like all of them though I'm sweet and
sour mainly though I do like it
well I guess I'm a loser where do you go
from there yeah I'll just shut the [ __ ]
up now uh no and then I'll do chicken
nuggies for sure uh then I'll do either
a Big Mac or a quarter pounder or a
quarterback two uh McDoubles I'll do
something like that you guys are
disgusting hold on I'm not even done yet
dude uh sometimes I'll do a hot spicy
McChicken or just a regular McChicken
feel free to name the whole menu too
sometimes yeah I got an Oreo McFlurry
you know what I'm saying and then
sometimes oh damn it's a tall order hold
on I'm not done can you stop it jeez
don't get that cheese danish in the
cinnamon roll it's so bad I ordered it
the cinnamon roll kind of it sucks ass
bro sucks ass yeah it's not that good I
ordered it last week that sounds like so
good I know because it's so [ __ ]
immature it hits so great it's like
but I also like the two cheeseburgers
too so and sometimes I like a filet fish
you want to change cards
[ __ ] SDS for useful I'm gonna make a
rib in a while though you know he's just
wanting to make ribbons back you guys
want to go no all right
I don't like the McRib you don't like it
okay no I don't like it uh I like um
chicken nuggets of course you do peas
fries no salt medium what the [ __ ] and
then uh huh
salt I have no salt bro because they
make it fresh
yourself after sometimes but ketchup
ketchup's already salty you're crazy and
then I either get a McDouble or a double
hamburger because sometimes like I don't
want cheese but well you don't like what
is a McDouble a McDouble is a double
cheeseburger but with just one cheese
like one slice in between the two
patties and that's on the menu That's
the value menu yeah and then they also
have a double cheeseburger yeah it's
like a cheeseburger but with two patties
whereas the Double Quarter Pounder with
cheese is like two quarter pound patties
so it's just different meat like if
you're watching your weight you know
then you want to like
but I usually get those I just just get
those three things so don't go to
McDonald's and then uh what's super
underrated at McDonald's is the soft
serve the vanilla ice cream oh that is
that's just bad it's underrated it's
underrated because you don't go to
McDonald's just for ice cream people go
over there for the Nuggets sometimes if
you go to McDonald's just for the video
interesting okay it's a McDonald's just
for ice cream because that's so many
chemicals not in vanilla yeah it's like
some other [ __ ] it's so soft the cone is
elevated but it's good though it's very
good the cone is crazy astronaut food or
something that's my go-to that's true
not food let's go to clean
um well I don't I don't eat McDonald's
[Music]
however growing up my mom would bribe my
brother and I with McDonald's in the
morning to get us to go to school early
so the breakfast was my favorite the
hash browns yeah the hash browns hey so
so when you go like say you're hungry
you're starving and you go to McDonald's
and you have to order something what do
you mean if I'm hungry and I'm starving
I'm not choosing no but just say you're
this just play along theoretical story
you're not gonna make a dent yeah it's
not it's not gonna happen so you just
order fry guys did you just order fries
I don't go
when somebody goes for you would you go
if there was a menu subset that said
McDonald's for her and it was like and
it was in a pink font
well I don't like babies so not not my
Democratic and it came with a free
Freddy Prince Junior toy
so out of touch with what women want
what do you go when you're you're hungry
and you're hangry and you need to make a
bad decision where do you go yeah or do
you only have good decisions Steakhouse
no boo
damn Taco Bell catch me in Beverly Hills
yeah you don't have a go-to like bad
decision place at Taco Bell Taco Bell so
what do you get what are you going to
talk about wait wait wait guys we're
staying on McDonald's thank you we still
got an article it's not an OTR we got an
article sorry we're six minutes in by
the way
what do you get at Taco Bell Crunchwrap
Supreme and I think that's pretty good
that's pretty good that's it number six
bro all right moving on move two State
chalupas last one don't no don't [ __ ]
change ooh steak to lupus fine Ryan
we're not hearing what you gotta say
we're going straight to it McDonald's
CEO explains why it takes people's
favorite items off the menu because he's
a [ __ ] [ __ ]
bro hey low-key McDonald's you're gonna
have a pretty fire grilled chicken
sandwich that was kind of healthy The
Artisan Deluxe is kind of healthy kind
of healthy healthy it was actually
healthier look compared to everything
else is that why they took it off
because it sucked compared to everything
else where you're starting from is
already so bad you just get the chicken
sandwich though it was okay if you get
enough no mayo the macros were 36 grams
of protein and under six grams of fat
that's pretty [ __ ] good is it even
chicken yeah for sure for sure for sure
I'm like and like two grams of saturated
fat come on all right good all right all
right well why do you think uh they take
things off the menu and they never
return because nobody buys make an
artificial scarcity because of Super
Size Me No that movie made me hungry
maybe even more maybe you want to have
it yeah
to make his body look more [ __ ] up
maybe I don't know or he just have to
get him fatter tits at the end
exactly uh the CEO says checked right
now man that he gets asked all the time
he gets asked all the time why they take
certain things off the menu and the
answer is very very basic but we just
want all of our fellow McDonald's
[Music]
rebellions to know out there
um he says and what I say uh is we put
on the menu what sells I have people who
say why don't you have the Egg White
Delight anymore yeah because he says
well because you didn't buy it when we
did so yes I did that's that's not a
nice that's not a nice thing to say
though because if one dude was buying it
religiously every day they would still
cancel if not enough dudes were like
that exactly that makes you feel like
[ __ ] I bought that every day and then uh
what one thing you could do too is you
add like two more egg whites in there
and then boom you got more egg white or
Chick-fil-A got the egg white deluxe
like a white grill a sandwich really
good it's like 30 grams of protein
nutritionist yeah but I I don't think
people are going to McDonald's to make
healthy they should just open up a
second but some people but some people
that's all they got so they gotta make
do with what they got that's all they
got they are on the go they are also
adding a news every McDonald on every
street they are adding a new menu item
permanently and they haven't done that
in like over 15 years what is it what is
it oh what are they eliminating Anthony
you're adding he's this oh thank you for
paying attention sort of they are adding
a new menu item permanently to the menu
that has not they have not permanently
added something to the menu in in over a
decade let me guess give it to me so go
ahead crispy chicken sandwich it's
almost but it's not called that I would
think that too because of the [ __ ]
competitive chicken thing yeah but it's
called the mick well wait what is it
called it's not to make chicken I know
it's not but it's like chicken's already
there you're right there come on man no
right there MC crispy be crispy that's
it there you go that's it crispy de los
Pollo
[Laughter]
how come chicken is so in style all of
us
wow you speak Spanish I speak a lot of
things yeah it's the first permanent
chicken burger added to McDonald's menu
in 15 years so basically
um to answer Bart's question why is
chicken why is chicken in bar why is it
so [ __ ] in style right now I don't
know he asked the question again
everybody it started with Popeyes the
fried chicken sandwich right as far as
like fast food wise it's all the one
that people were trying to kill people
for yeah but they probably copied the
Nashville Hot Chicken [ __ ] exactly
but then but then as far as like The
Craze that every like Wingstop has
there's a race it's it's really good I
mean like everybody has a [ __ ] so do
you guys want to change lunch to
Chick-fil-A yes or or I'm down hey you
want the real answer why this is [ __ ]
Heaven I'll tell you the real thing yeah
if you guys know your jokes
okay Junior you get a real one I'll give
it a real one what's the reason what's
the reason so countries when they make
too much of a thing they make an
artificial uh race to sell it just like
Canada did with bacon we do the same
thing with chicken we just got too many
chickens we got a lot of people say you
don't want to eat chicken no more so
cause a deficit how many so they made
too many supply and demand
done is everyone well for sure that's my
theory I don't know
the way I look at it is like whenever
you know like countries in GDP and the
things that they make when they make too
much of it they they're just too much
[ __ ] so like you can't even have a
chicken race unless you have way too
many chickens they got to do some sort
of marketing campaign yeah but they did
do that in Canada with bacon because
bacon was not a popular thing but they
just had too many of those cuts that
they weren't selling and then so to make
bacon a thing they made it a thing
so they lied to us
is a lie to the people it's like what
your parents do when they have too much
food or like too much of like a fish you
don't like so there's just leftovers
that's it you had too much food in your
house I have too much of a fish I didn't
like yeah you got a little bit of the
inside of me right there yeah well I
wasn't crazy about it
[Music]